A couple of months ago, I happened to see, for the first time as an adult, the old Disney cartoon Snow White. It's kind of amazing, really. It's Walt Disney's first animated feature, made back in 1937, and when you watch it, it almost feels more like an opera than like a modern movie. Snow White and the prince and the seven dwarfs each enter the film in this very stagey way, each of them singing a song that declares who they are and what it is they want.
几个月前，我成年后第一次偶然看了那部老迪斯尼动画片《白雪公主》。真的，太不可思议了。那是华特·迪士尼在1937年制作的第一部动画长片，当你观看它时，它给人的感觉更像是一部歌剧，而不是现代电影。白雪公主、王子和七个小矮人各自以这种极具舞台感的方式登场，每个人都唱着一首歌，宣告他们是谁，以及他们想要什么。
[SINGING] I'm wishing-- I'm wishing-- for the one I love--
[唱歌] 我许愿——我许愿——为了我所爱的人——
Snow White, for instance, sings to her reflection in a wishing well, and her voice echoes back.
例如，白雪公主对着许愿井里的倒影唱歌，她的声音回荡着。
[SINGING] Today. I'm hoping-- I'm hoping-- and I'm dreaming of, the nice thing-- the nice thing-- you say-- you say.
[唱歌] 今天。我希望——我希望——我梦想着，美好的事物——美好的事物——你说——你说。
And in fact, she meets the prince that very day. So I mentioned this to my sister who works for Disney-- she's a film executive there-- that I'd seen Snow White and how it felt like an old opera and how old-fashioned the opening songs were. And she goes no, no, no, no, no. It's not that it's like an opera. What you're hearing is just the "I Wish" song. And she tells me this is a standard thing, that this is in lots of movies. And the way it works is this. The very first song that the main character sings, they declare what it is that they want, and then that is what gets the story going. It's the "I Wish" song.
事实上，她就在那天遇见了王子。所以我跟在迪斯尼工作的姐姐提到了这件事——她是那里的电影主管——说我看了《白雪公主》，觉得它很像一部老歌剧，开场的歌曲多么过时。她说：“不，不，不，不，不。它不是像歌剧。你听到的是‘我希望’之歌。”她告诉我这是一种标准，在很多电影里都有。它是这样运作的：主角唱的第一首歌，他们宣告他们想要什么，然后这就推动了故事的发展。这就是“我希望”之歌。
[SINGING] I want more.
[唱歌] 我想要更多。
For instance, the Little Mermaid, Karen says, sings about her wish to be human.
比如凯伦说，《小美人鱼》唱的是她想成为人类的愿望。
[SINGING] I want to be where the people are. I wanna see, wanna see them dancin'. Walking around on those-- what do call 'em? Oh-- feet!
[唱歌] 我想去人类所在的地方。我想看，想看他们跳舞。走在那上面——叫什么来着？哦——脚！
Quasimodo, in the Disney version of The Hunchback of Notre Dame sings this from his tower as his first song.
在迪斯尼版的《巴黎圣母院》中，卡西莫多在塔楼上唱了这首歌作为他的第一首歌。
[SINGING] Safe behind these windows and these parapets of stone. Gazing at the people down below me. All my life I watch them as I hide up here alone. Hungry for the histories they show me. All my life I wonder how it feels to pass a day. Not above them, but part of them. And out there--
[唱歌] 安全地躲在窗户和石栏杆后面。凝视着下面的人们。我一生都在躲在这里独自观察他们。渴望着他们展示的历史。我一生都在想，过上一天会是什么感觉。不是在他们之上，而是他们的一部分。在外面的世界——
OK, hold up. I'm going to stop that. That is just too uplifting. Anyway, this phenomenon, the "I Wish" song, goes way beyond Disney films.
好了，打住。我得停一下。这太振奋人心了。总之，这种“我希望”之歌的现象，远远超出了迪斯尼电影。
[SINGING] Somewhere over the rainbow, way up--
[唱歌] 彩虹之上，高高之上——
This, of course, is the "I Wish" that Dorothy delivers at the beginning of The Wizard of Oz to go over the rainbow.
这当然是多萝西在《绿野仙踪》开头为了越过彩虹而发出的“我希望”。
[SINGING] There's a land that I heard of once in a lullaby.
[唱歌] 有个地方我在摇篮曲里听说过。
It turns out lots of old stage musicals begin with the "I Wish" song. Fiddler on the Roof has the daughter singing matchmaker, make me a match. Funny Girl has Barbara Streisand singing about becoming a star. My Fair Lady opens with Julie Andrews wishing for a room somewhere, far away from the cold night air. And Stephen Sondheim, ever the virtuous in this kind of thing, in "Into the Woods" has six different characters singing the various "I Wishes" in the opening.
事实证明，许多古老的舞台音乐剧都以“我希望”之歌开头。《屋顶上的提琴手》里女儿唱着《媒人，为我做个媒》。《妙女郎》里芭芭拉·史翠珊唱着想要成为明星。 《窈窕淑女》开场是朱莉·安德鲁斯希望在一个房间里，远离寒冷的夜晚空气。斯蒂芬·桑德海姆，在这种事情上一直是个行家，在《魔法黑森林》的开场中，有六个不同的角色唱着各自的“我希望”。
[SINGING] I wish--
[唱歌] 我希望——
[SINGING] The King is giving a Festival.
[唱歌] 国王正在举办节日。
[SINGING] More than life.
[唱歌] 胜过生命。
[SINGING] I wish--
[唱歌] 我希望——
[SINGING] I wish to go to the Festival.
[唱歌] 我希望能去节日。
[SINGING] More than riches--
[唱歌] 胜过财富——
[SINGING] And the Ball--
[唱歌] 还有舞会——
[SINGING] I wish my cow would give us some milk.
[唱歌] 我希望我的牛能给我们一些牛奶。
[SINGING] More than anything--
[唱歌] 胜过一切——
[SINGING] I wish we had a child.
[唱歌] 我希望我们有一个孩子。
[SINGING] Please, pal, please, pal--
[唱歌] 请，伙计，请，伙计——
[SINGING] I wish to go to the Festival.
[唱歌] 我希望能去节日。
[SINGING] I wish you'd give us some milk or even cheese-- I wish.
[唱歌] 我希望你能给我们一些牛奶，甚至奶酪——我希望。
[SINGING] I wish we might have a child.
[唱歌] 我希望我们能有个孩子。
[SINGING] I wish.
[唱歌] 我希望。
My sister Karen said that even the Britney Spears movie Crossroads begins with an "I Wish" song. Britney is dancing on her bed in her underwear, singing into a spoon, like it's a microphone, to a Madonna song on her stereo about a girl wants to be a star, which is what she comes by the end of the movie.
我姐姐凯伦说，就连布兰妮·斯皮尔斯的电影《十字路口》也以“我希望”之歌开头。布兰妮穿着内衣在床上跳舞，拿着勺子当麦克风唱歌，那是她立体声音响里放的一首麦当娜的歌，唱的是一个女孩想成为明星，而这正是她在电影结尾所达到的目标。
[SINGING] I've had to work much harder than this. For something I want don't try to resist me. Open your heart to me--
[唱歌] 我必须比这更努力工作。为了我想要的东西，不要试图拒绝我。向我敞开心扉——
When somebody points out to you how common this is, you start to see the "I Wish" song everywhere. And if you're host of your own national radio show, you start to think why haven't we done that? Why don't we ever start the show with a song--
当有人向你指出这有多普遍时，你就会开始到处看到“我希望”之歌。如果你是自己全国广播节目的主持人，你就会开始想，为什么我们没这样做过？为什么我们从不用一首歌来开始节目——
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
--where I express my hopes and my dreams for what the show will be today.
——在那里我表达了我对今天节目的希望和梦想。
[SINGING] Oh, the woman in Act 1 is wistful, but funny in a quiet way. And the guy in Act 2 has a tough job to do, a mission that's gone on 20 days. I only wish their stories will be gripping and special, even though it's not the news and they're not stars. You remember what they said, you'll mention them at dinner, and when their on you will not leave your cars. Because it's radio. Stories on the radio can be funny or emotional, can fill you with longing. My wish is that today's show lives up to this song. And bring on the conflict. Make the people speak. Bring on that music we use every week. I wish for radio, decent stories on the radio.
[唱歌] 哦，第一幕中的女人很怀旧，但有一种安静的幽默感。第二幕中的那个家伙有艰巨的工作要做，一个已经持续了20天的任务。我只希望他们的故事会引人入胜且特别，即使这不是新闻，他们也不是明星。你会记住他们说的话，你会在晚餐时提到他们，当他们在广播时，你不会离开你的车。因为这是广播。广播里的故事可以是幽默的或感性的，可以让你充满渴望。我的希望是今天的节目不负这首歌。让冲突开始吧。让人说话。带来我们每周使用的那种音乐。我希望有广播，广播里有像样的故事。
[SPEAKING] Yes, friends. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. You know, those old movies and shows with the "I Wish" songs, they were stories of people trying to achieve some dream, trying to get to some promised land. And here this week at This American Life, we filled our show with stories like that. Stories of dreamers, stories of people who want to reach a place that they've only heard about. We have three stories in three acts. Starlee Kine, David Rakoff and Hillary Frank.
[说话] 是的，朋友们。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你知道，那些带有“我希望”之歌的老电影和节目，它们是关于人们努力实现某种梦想、努力到达某种应许之地的故事。本周在《美国生活》，我们的节目也充满了这样的故事。梦想家的故事，那些想要到达他们只听说过的地方的人的故事。我们有三个故事，分三个章节。斯塔莉·凯恩、大卫·拉科夫和希拉里·弗兰克。
[SINGING] Oh, I wish that you'll stay here and la-cha-da-da. Please don't say goodbye or I'll see ya. You know you want to hear the final words we have from Torey Malatia.
[唱歌] 哦，我希望你会留在这里，啦-恰-达-达。请不要说再见，否则我会见到你。你知道你想听到托里·马拉蒂亚的最后感言。
[SPEAKING] Stuff's coming up, friends. So stay with us, eh?
[说话] 节目马上开始，朋友们。敬请关注，嗯？
Act One. Across the Street from Heaven. Well, decades of "I Wish" songs, sung by cartoon characters, spawned an entire empire of "I Wish." Disney films led to Disney theme parks. And at least for now, until the whole thing gets bought up by a big cable company, they're still there, emitting a whole fog of "I Wish" over small children. Starlee Kine tells this story, a true story, about a wish from her own childhood.
第一章。天堂街对面。几十年来，“我希望”之歌，由卡通人物演唱，催生了一个完整的“我希望”帝国。迪斯尼电影导致了迪斯尼主题公园的出现。至少目前为止，在这一切被一家大型有线电视公司收购之前，它们仍然存在，在小孩身上散发着一阵“我希望”的迷雾。斯塔莉·凯恩讲述了这个故事，一个真实的故事，关于她童年的一个愿望。
I guess my mom was what you'd call overprotective. When I would sleep over at a friend's house, the parents would inevitably receive a call around 3:00 in the morning from my mom, asking if they please wouldn't mind holding a mirror up to my mouth to make sure I was still breathing. After that, it was pretty hard to get invited back.
我想我妈妈是个所谓的保护过度的人。当我到朋友家过夜时，我妈妈难免会在凌晨3点左右给对方父母打电话，问他们是否介意拿面镜子放在我嘴边，确认我是否还在呼吸。在那之后，我就很难再被邀请去了。
I wasn't allowed to play soccer because I might get brain damage or die of internal bleeding. I wasn't allowed to ride a school bus because the driver might kidnap me. I wasn't allowed to walk my dog down our peaceful suburban street. "It's much too dangerous out there," my mom would say. I pleaded with her for months and she finally agreed, on one condition. I could walk the dog one time around the block provided I leave a trail of popcorn behind me so I didn't get lost. Later, outside, when the neighbor kids asked me what I was doing, I pretended not to hear them.
我不被允许踢足球，因为我可能会脑损伤或死于内出血。我不被允许坐校车，因为司机可能会绑架我。我不被允许在宁静的郊区街道上遛狗。“外面太危险了，”我妈妈会说。我求了她好几个月，她终于同意了，但有一个条件：我可以遛狗绕街区一圈，前提是我必须留下一串爆米花作为踪迹，这样我就不会迷路。后来，在外面，当邻居家的孩子问我在做什么时，我假装没听见。
This pattern would repeat itself many times over the years. I'd ask to do something, my mom would refuse. I'd beg her to change her mind, and when she finally did, the compromise she came up with was so strange and complicated that I'd often wish she'd just kept saying no. Take what happened with Disneyland. A kid growing up in LA can get tired of Disneyland at an early age. 10-year-olds talk about it as though it was a phase they went through when they were young, like when they used to kiss the bear on the Snuggles box. Yeah, Disneyland's all right, I guess. I mean, if you're into that sort of thing.
多年来，这种模式重复了很多次。我会要求做某事，妈妈会拒绝。我会求她改变主意，当她终于答应时，她想出的折衷方案是如此奇怪和复杂，以至于我经常希望她坚持拒绝就好了。就拿迪斯尼乐园的事来说吧。在洛杉矶长大的孩子很早就对迪斯尼乐园感到厌倦。10岁的孩子谈论它时，好像那是他们年轻时经历的一个阶段，就像他们过去亲吻《舒适》包装盒上的小熊一样。是的，迪斯尼乐园还可以，我想。我的意思是，如果你喜欢那种东西的话。
My sister and I, however, were different. By the time I was nine and she was six, we'd still never been to Disneyland. My mom thought it was way too dangerous. She arrived at this conclusion during one of her daily trials through the morning paper, scanning for dangers that could befall her children. Somewhere in the back, she'd found an article about a faulty ride at a fair in a small town somewhere in the Midwest, and that was enough to seal our fate for years. No matter how much evidence we provided to the contrary, no matter how much we begged or whined or threatened to stop eating and drinking for 30 days, she still wouldn't budge.
然而，我和我妹妹不同。当我九岁、她六岁时，我们还从未去过迪斯尼乐园。我妈觉得太危险了。她在每天浏览晨报的过程中得出这个结论，扫描着可能降临到她孩子身上的危险。在报纸的某个角落，她发现了一篇关于中西部某个小镇游乐场设施故障的文章，这就注定了我们多年的命运。无论我们提供多少相反的证据，无论我们怎么乞求、抱怨或威胁说要连续30天不吃不喝，她就是不为所动。
But just as we were about to give up for good, my mother had a change of heart. Perhaps the guilt had finally gotten to her. In any case, she decided to throw us a bone. She still wouldn't take us to Disneyland. She hadn't totally lost her mind after all. But she would let us do the next best thing. For two weeks, we could stay at the Disneyland Hotel.
但就在我们准备彻底放弃时，我妈妈改变了主意。也许是愧疚感终于击中了她。总之，她决定给我们一点甜头。她仍然不会带我们去迪斯尼乐园。毕竟她还没完全疯掉。但她会让我们做第二好的选择：连续两周，我们可以住在迪斯尼酒店。
Judging by the look on her face, you could tell my mom was pretty pleased by this proposition. She beamed at us expectantly, her arms outstretched. All we could manage to do was shrug our shoulders and nod.
从她脸上的表情可以看出，我妈妈对这个提议感到非常满意。她期待地看着我们，双臂张开。我们唯一能做的就是耸耸肩，点了点头。
When the time came to leave, we packed up our little suitcases. We threw in our favorite toys and games. I carefully folded in a fresh unopened pack of Mad Libs I'd been saving for a special occasion. My mom made sandwiches for the ride and packed extra clothes for us in case it got too cold or too hot. She turned the air conditioning on in the car and waited until it was nice and freezing inside before letting us in. She didn't want us to get heat stroke. Then she pulled out of our driveway, and we were off.
出发的时间到了，我们收拾好我们的小行李箱。我们扔进了我们最喜欢的玩具和游戏。我小心地折进了一包我一直留着准备特殊场合用的未开封的《疯狂填字》游戏。妈妈为旅途做了三明治，还为我们多带了衣服，以防太冷或太热。她打开车里的空调，等到里面凉得舒服了才让我们进去。她不想让我们中暑。然后她把车开出车道，我们就出发了。
15 minutes later, we were pulling into the parking lot of the Disneyland Hotel. My mom told me to keep track of where we parked, and I made a mental note that we were in the Goofy section.
15分钟后，我们开进了迪斯尼酒店的停车场。我妈让我记住车停在哪儿，我心里记下我们停在“高飞”区。
The Disneyland parking lot was literally across the street. It was filled to capacity with lines of cars stretching as far as the eye could see. Behind them, I could make out the top of Space Mountain. That's how close we were. We headed to the hotel and into the lobby. The receptionist looked at us and smiled. She leaned down and asked me where we were visiting from. I pretended that I didn't hear her.
迪斯尼酒店的停车场就在马路对面。它停满了车，车队一眼望不到头。在它们后面，我能隐约看到太空山的顶端。我们离得就是这么近。我们走向酒店进入大堂。接待员看着我们笑了笑。她俯下身问我是从哪里来的。我假装没听见。
For the next three years, we'd go to the Disneyland Hotel for two weeks twice a year without ever crossing the street over into Disneyland proper. Whenever we forgot something, like a toothbrush or a raincoat, we'd buy a new one instead of driving the 15 minutes home to pick it up. This made us feel more like we were on vacation.
接下来的三年里，我们每年两次去迪斯尼酒店住两周，却从没跨过马路走进迪斯尼乐园本部。每当我们忘记什么东西，比如牙刷或雨衣，我们就会买新的，而不是开车15分钟回家去拿。这让我们感觉更像是在度假。
Before I ever saw the hotel, I pictured a giant treehouse with branches stretching in every direction and little Do Not Disturb signs hanging from their tips. But in reality, the rooms weren't all that different from any other hotels, which wasn't a bad thing. They had everything a little kid loves about staying in a hotel. The comforters were scratchy, and the beds were springy and fun to jump on. And we could've spent days pressing the button on the ice machine.
在我还没见过这家酒店之前，我把它想象成一个巨大的树屋，枝桠向四面八方延伸，尖端挂着“请勿打扰”的牌子。但实际上，房间和其他酒店没什么不同，这并不是坏事。它们拥有一切小孩子喜欢住酒店的原因：被子很粗糙，床很有弹性，跳起来很有趣。我们可以花上一整天按冰块机的按钮。
The only problem was that we were constantly being reminded of what we didn't have. There was a picture of the Magic Kingdom on the ashtrays, on the complimentary notepads, on the soap, even worked into the paisley pattern of the curtains. When you ordered room service, the kids' menu also doubled as a Mickey Mouse mask. You just had to poke out the two slits for eyes and place the hooks over your ears. Then when you looked in the mirror, you could see Mickey's face looking back at you.
唯一的问题是，我们不断地被提醒我们没有得到的东西。烟灰缸、免费记事本、肥皂上都有魔法王国的图片，甚至连窗帘的佩斯利花纹里都融入了它。当你点客房送餐时，儿童菜单还可以变身成米老鼠面具。你只需要戳出两个眼孔，然后把钩子套在耳朵上。然后当你照镜子时，你会看到米奇的脸回望着你。
This wouldn't have been half as bad if not for the fact that the real Mickey Mouse wouldn't have been caught dead in that hotel. He was much too famous. Instead we had to settle for the second- and third-tier characters, who walked around like they owned the joint. We soon had more autographs by J. Worthington Foulfellow-- the oily fox who lures Pinocchio away from school-- than we knew what to do with. My sister and I would ask him when Mickey was coming, but he'd just shrug his shoulders and do a little dance.
如果真正的米老鼠会出现在那家酒店，情况可能还没那么糟。他太出名了。相反，我们不得不接受那些二三流的角色，他们到处走，就像那是他们的地盘一样。很快，我们就拥有了太多“J.沃辛顿·福尔福”——那个引诱匹诺曹逃学的油滑狐狸的亲笔签名，多到不知道该怎么办。我和我妹妹会问他米奇什么时候来，但他只会耸耸肩，跳一小段舞。
We had a perfect view of Disneyland from our room. We'd watch people line up outside the entrance an hour before it even opened. At night, we could see the glow of the Electric Light Parade moving down Main Street. At first we were sure mom would cave. There was just no way she couldn't. She taken us, her two precious children, her whole reason for living, to the funnest place on Earth, only to stop 50 feet shy of the fun. It was like she was dangling the fun in front of us to see how long we could  go on grabbing at the air before finally collapsing of exhaustion.
从我们的房间可以看到迪斯尼乐园的完美景观。我们会看着人们在开园前一小时就在入口处排队。晚上，我们可以看到电动花车游行沿着主街缓缓移动。起初，我们确信妈妈会妥协。她没理由不妥协。她把我们，她两个珍贵的孩子，她生活的全部意义，带到了地球上最有趣的地方，却在离快乐不到50英尺的地方停下了。就像她把快乐悬在我们面前，看我们要多久才会因为疲惫而瘫倒之前，一直抓着空气。
There was a monorail that took the hotel guests directly to the park. It looked like something out of the Jetsons. In the beginning, my sister and I hung out in front of the monorail all the time. We'd bring our coloring books and Connect Four pieces and just camp out. We'd even eat our lunch there. We were like dogs waiting behind the door for our owner to finally open it and let us out. Every time we heard footsteps, we'd perk up our ears, hoping it was our mom coming to tell us it was time. We were ready, but she never came.
有一条单轨列车直接把酒店客人送到公园。它看起来像是《杰森一家》里的东西。起初，我和我妹妹一直待在单轨列车前。我们会带着涂色书和四子棋棋子在那里驻扎。我们甚至在那里吃午饭。我们就像等在门后的狗，等着主人终于打开门放我们出去。每次听到脚步声，我们就竖起耳朵，希望是妈妈来告诉我们时间到了。我们准备好了，但她从未来过。
To pass the time, my sister and I became experts at the various kid activities the hotel had to offer. We could assemble the Donald Duck popsicle stick faces with our eyes closed. The hotel had a fake beach  next to the pool even though the real beach was only 10 minutes away. Every hour, a judge with a whistle around his neck would give an award for the best sand castle. The prize was five Disney dollars, valid for use only at Disneyland. My sister and I always won because we never had to get up and leave. The other kids would barely have managed their first tunnel, while we would already be adding on a second level to the carriage house in back.
为了打发时间，我和我妹妹成了酒店提供的各种儿童活动的专家。我们可以闭着眼组装唐老鸭冰棒棍脸。酒店在游泳池旁边有一个假沙滩，尽管真正的沙滩距离那里只有10分钟路程。每个小时，一名脖子上挂着哨子的裁判会为最好的沙堡颁奖。奖品是五张迪斯尼美元，只能在迪斯尼乐园使用。我和我妹妹总是赢，因为我们不需要起身离开。其他孩子刚搭好第一个隧道，我们就已经开始给后面的马车房加第二层了。
We eventually got to know the different people who worked there. The guys who sang in the fake barbershop quartet, who didn't like each other at all. The mime who frankly seemed to be phoning it in. The man who sold churos that we bought for dinner. My favorite, however, was a caricature artist. We'd always wait until the last night of our trip to get our caricature done. We liked to save it for the end. The caricature artist would ask what we enjoyed doing most, and we'd tell him whatever we were into at the time. When I was nine, I had just gotten a new dog. The caricature artist drew my dog and me riding Space Mountain. He made my dog look like Pluto. His paws are sticking up in the air.
我们最终认识了在那里工作的不同的人。在假理发店四重唱里唱歌的人，他们一点也不喜欢对方。那个看上去是在敷衍了事的默剧演员。卖吉事果的男人，我们把吉事果当晚饭买。不过，我最喜欢的是一位漫画艺术家。我们总是等到旅行的最后一晚才去画我们的漫画。我们喜欢把它留到最后。漫画艺术家会问我们最喜欢做什么，我们会告诉他当时喜欢什么。我九岁时，刚得到了一只新狗。漫画艺术家画了我骑在太空山上，还画了我的狗。他把我的狗画得像布鲁托。它的爪子向上伸着。
My mom still has these caricatures. They cover an entire wall of her house, picture after picture, the way other parents display photos of their kids. If you look at them in order, you can actually see us grow up before your very eyes, our oversized heads and little bodies acquiring different hairstyles and fashions over the years. There I am in fourth grade, learning how to swim. The caricaturist drew me jumping into a tiny bucket of water. In fifth grade, I discovered boys, and you can see me and Kirk Cameron riding a tandem bicycle. Sixth grade was my dark phase, where I didn't think I was interested in anything. The caricaturist just drew me standing in line for the Pirates of the Caribbean, rolling my eyes and looking surly.
我妈妈现在还留着这些漫画。它们挂满了她家的一整面墙，一张接一张，就像其他父母展示孩子照片那样。如果你按顺序看它们，你实际上可以看到我们在你眼前长大，我们硕大的脑袋和小身体随着年龄的增长换上了不同的发型和时尚。看，那是四年级的我，正在学游泳。漫画家画我跳进一个小水桶里。五年级时，我发现了男生，你可以看到我和柯克·卡梅隆骑着双人自行车。六年级是我阴暗的时期，我觉得自己对什么都不感兴趣。漫画家只是画我排队等着坐加勒比海盗，翻着白眼，看起来很阴沉。
The hotel was literally brimming with children, a lot like how I imagined Never Never Land to be. Everywhere you turned, you spotted one, hiding behind a potted plant or laying under the continental breakfast buffet table. It was like their parents had surrendered all control of them. You'd get in an elevator, and there'd be at least a dozen kids, dressed however they saw fit. One wore a snorkel on his head even though he wasn't going to the pool. One wore a sneaker on his right foot and a cowboy boot on his left. Several of them wore capes made out of hotel pillowcases. Within seconds, some kid would push every one of the elevator buttons, and the other kids, deep in conversation with one another, would clap distractedly. If there were any adults in there with us, they'd roll their eyes, but not even all that much. They knew this place was for us.
酒店里挤满了孩子，就像我想象中的永无岛一样。无论你转向哪里，都会发现一个，躲在盆栽后面，或者躺在欧式自助早餐桌下。就像他们的父母已经放弃了对他们的所有控制。你走进电梯，里面至少有十几个孩子，穿着他们觉得合适的衣服。一个人头上戴着呼吸管，尽管他不去游泳池。一个人右脚穿着运动鞋，左脚穿着牛仔靴。他们中的几个人戴着酒店枕套做的斗篷。几秒钟内，某个孩子就会按下每一个电梯按钮，而其他正沉浸在彼此谈话中的孩子们会心不在焉地鼓掌。如果电梯里有大人，他们会翻个白眼，但不会多说什么。他们知道这个地方是给我们的。
My sister and I made friends with these kids whenever we could. Timing was key. It was imperative that we catch them before they made the trek across the street. After that, we'd lose our edge. So every night we'd hang out by the checkout desk and await the new arrivals. We'd sidle up to them while their parents were checking in and ask them where they were from. We told them that we knew the hotel pretty well, so they should stick with us. We knew how to get stuff. "Would you like extra marshmallows with your hot chocolate?" we'd say. "The room service guy is a friend of ours. How about extra whipped cream?"
我和我妹妹尽可能地和这些孩子交朋友。时机很关键。必须在他们动身跨过马路之前抓住他们。在那之后，我们就失去了优势。所以每天晚上，我们都会在结账台旁闲逛，等待新来的客人。当他们的父母办理入住手续时，我们会溜到他们身边，问他们是从哪里来的。我们告诉他们我们很熟悉这家酒店，所以他们应该跟着我们。我们知道怎么搞到东西。“你们想在热巧克力里多加点棉花糖吗？”我们会说。“客房服务员是我们的朋友。多加点鲜奶油怎么样？”
We'd spend a few hours with them or, if we were lucky and it rained, a full day. Then these kids would head off to the park. My sister and I would be waiting outside the monorail when they returned. They'd climb off, all loaded down with souvenirs, looking pink and exhausted. But in their eyes, we detected a change. They'd seen things we couldn't even begin to imagine, and we couldn't think of anything to say to them. After a few days when they checked out of the hotel, none of them bothered to say goodbye.
我们会和他们呆几个小时，或者如果运气好下雨的话，就呆上一整天。然后这些孩子会出发去乐园。当他们回来时，我和我妹妹会在单轨列车站台外等着。他们走下车，带着满满的纪念品，脸红红的，筋疲力尽。但在他们的眼里，我们察觉到了一种变化。他们见到了我们根本无法想象的事情，而我们想不出什么可说的。几天后，当他们从酒店结账退房时，没人会说再见。
We did finally make it to Disneyland as kids when I was 11 and my sister was 8, and it happened in the most random way possible, like a piano falling out of the sky onto our heads. One morning, long after my sister and I had stopped asking, my mom just said, "Hey, guys. Do you want to go to Disneyland?" It was a school day. We had no idea where this uncharacteristic burst of spontaneity was coming from, but my sister and I had learned by now not to question these things.
我和我妹妹最终在11岁和8岁时以孩子的身份去了迪斯尼乐园，这件事发生得非常随机，就像一架钢琴从天而降落在我们头上。一天早上，很久没再问过这事的我们，妈妈突然说：“嘿，伙计们。想去迪斯尼乐园吗？”那是个上学的日子。我们不知道这种突如其来的自发性是从哪来的，但我和我妹妹已经学会了不去质疑这些事情。
Once we are finally inside the gates, my sister and I knew exactly where to go. There had been a map of the park with illustrations of all the different rides in the hotel lobby. We studied it so long we had it memorized. But the real Disneyland was different than the one we'd imagined for so long. It was strange to see that it was a natural place with long lines and smelly bathrooms. When I climbed onto a ride, I was surprised by how solid the seat felt. When you think of fantasy places in your head, you never think about the fact that they're plastic, that the overhead bar might pinch your neck. We thought it was great.
一旦我们最终进了大门，我和我妹妹就知道该去哪儿。酒店大堂里有一张公园地图，上面有所有不同游乐设施的插图。我们研究了太久，早就背下来了。但真正的迪斯尼乐园和我们想象了那么久的那个不同。奇怪的是，它是一个自然的地方，有长长的队伍和难闻的厕所。当我爬上一个游乐设施时，我对自己感觉到的座位那么坚硬感到惊讶。当你脑子里想到梦幻的地方时，你从没想过它们是塑料做的，头顶的栏杆可能会夹住你的脖子。我们觉得这很棒。
My mom, of course, wouldn't let us go on everything. She said the Matterhorn looked like it was about to fall apart, and we knew Thunder Mountain was out of the question. But we didn't care. She seemed more relaxed that day than we'd ever seen her. She laughed her head off in the tea cups. And when my sister got a paper cut from the salted pretzel wrapper, my mom just gave it a kiss instead of rushing her to the Emergency Room.
当然，我妈妈不会让我们玩所有的项目。她说马特洪峰看起来快要散架了，我们知道雷山当然也不可能。但我们不在乎。那天她看起来比我们见过的任何时候都放松。她在茶杯游戏里笑得前仰后合。当我妹妹被咸椒盐卷饼包装纸割破手指时，我妈妈只是亲吻了一下，而不是急着把她送进急诊室。
We were getting our Mickey Mouse hats embroidered with our names when our mom came up to us and told us to follow her. She led us to the ticket office in front and asked the lady for three annual passes: one adult and two kids. The passes meant we could come to Disneyland any time we wanted that year for free. The lady took our ID photograph for the card, my sister and I each wearing the same stunned expression on our face.
当我们正要把米老鼠帽子上绣上我们的名字时，妈妈走到我们身边，叫我们跟着她。她带我们到前面的售票处，向女士要了三张年票：一张成人的，两张儿童的。这意味着我们那一年可以随时免费来迪斯尼乐园。那位女士为卡片拍了我们的身份证照片，我和我妹妹脸上都带着同样的震惊表情。
The thing is, we never went back that year. We didn't use the passes once. Before going, my sister and I had been sure that once we were there, we'd never want to leave. Nothing was more important than being allowed inside. But now that we'd actually seen what it was, it's not that we were disappointed, but it just didn't loom so big anymore. We kept meaning to go back, but other things kept coming up.
问题是，那一年我们再也没去过。我们一次都没用过这些票。在去之前，我和我妹妹很确定，一旦到了那里，我们就再也不想离开。没有什么比被允许进入更重要的了。但现在我们真的看到了它是什么，并不是说我们失望了，而是它不再显得那么重要了。我们一直打算回去，但总有别的事情发生。
Finally, when I was 18, I returned. That year, my prom was held at the Disneyland Hotel. Being there as a teenager with my friends, it was hard to believe it had all ever happened. I didn't want anyone to find out, but I just knew the place too well. At one point, one girl wondered aloud where the bathroom was. "Oh, it's just down the hall about 20 paces," I said. "Past the storage room, but before the Lost and Found. Just make a left, then a right, and then another right, and you're there." Everyone stared at me, and I felt my cheeks go red.
最后，当我18岁时，我回来了。那一年，我的毕业舞会在迪斯尼酒店举行。作为一个十几岁的孩子和朋友们在那里，很难相信这一切真的发生过。我不想让任何人发现，但我就是太了解这个地方了。有一次，一个女孩大声问厕所在哪儿。“哦，顺着走廊走20步就到了，”我说。“过了储藏室，但在失物招领处之前。左转，再右转，然后再右转，就到了。”大家都盯着我，我感到脸颊发烫。
My mom, of course, initially didn't want me to go to prom at all. She worried about some kind of accident on the road, about the limo getting a flat and a crazy person picking us up and killing us all. About drinking, about my friends, about my dress, about my date. The only way I was able to calm her down was when I told her where the prom was being held-- the Disneyland Hotel. Her shoulders immediately untensed when I said the words.
当然，我妈妈起初根本不想让我去参加舞会。她担心路上发生意外，担心豪华轿车爆胎，担心疯子把我们接走杀掉。担心喝酒，担心我的朋友，担心我的礼服，担心我的舞伴。我能让她冷静下来的唯一方法就是告诉她舞会在哪里举行——迪斯尼酒店。我说出这两个词时，她的肩膀立刻放松了下来。
In reality, of course, sending a group of teenagers off to be by themselves in a hotel is exactly the sort of thing a parent probably should worry about. And in retrospect, letting loose your daughters at six and nine years old without supervision of any kind in a hotel full of strangers and adults in masks was probably a lot more dangerous than walking across the street to take them on It's a Small, Small World. But my mom never saw it that way. For her, the Disneyland Hotel was always the safest place on Earth.
现实中，当然，让一群青少年独自待在酒店里确实是父母可能应该担心的事情。回想起来，让六岁和九岁的女儿在没有监督的情况下，在充满陌生人和戴面具成年人的酒店里散养，可能比过马路带她们去坐“小小世界”要危险得多。但我妈妈从不这么看。对她来说，迪斯尼酒店永远是地球上最安全的地方。
Starlee Kine. Coming up, an experiment in trying to reach enlightenment involving a man and six to eight ounces of vegetable broth. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
斯塔莉·凯恩。接下来，一个尝试达到启蒙境界的实验，涉及一个男人和六到八盎司的蔬菜汤。节目将在一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司继续播出。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Promised Land. Stories of people who wish to get somewhere they've never been.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题：应许之地。关于那些希望到达他们从未去过的地方的人们的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two. Life in the Fast Lane. There's an ancient idea that fasting can lead to moments of enlightenment. Jesus fasted for 40 days in the desert. The Buddha fasted, as did Pythagoras and Gandhi and George Bernard Shaw.
我们来到了节目的第二章。第二章：快车道上的生活。有一种古老的观点认为禁食可以带来启蒙时刻。耶稣在沙漠中禁食了40天。佛陀禁食过，毕达哥拉斯、甘地和萧伯纳也一样。
Is it possible that all that stands between us and genius and insight is food? Well, we wanted to find out if anyone could reach this promised land, and our contributor David Rakoff agreed to be the guinea pig in a little experiment. He went on a 20-day fast that was 14 days with no food, three days transitioning in and out on either side to find out if he would see God-- or some variant.
难道阻碍我们获得天赋和洞察力的仅仅是食物吗？嗯，我们想弄清楚是否有人能到达这个应许之地，我们的撰稿人大卫·拉科夫同意成为这项小实验的豚鼠。他进行了一次为期20天的禁食，其中14天不吃东西，两边各过渡三天，看看他是否能见到上帝——或者某种变体。
Let's start with a showstopper, shall we? For the next three weeks, my path to enlightenment goes like this. I'm to wake up, head to the bathroom, and give myself an enema. You heard me. Warm water, Chamomile tea, and eight drops of lemon juice. I'm to hold it in for 15 minutes, lying on a towel on the bathroom floor, passing the time by reading some sort of spiritual literature. I opt for The New York Times. This is followed by a shower and a breakfast of 8 to 12 ounces of clear vegetable broth. At other points during the day, and I cannot say exactly when because this is copyrighted proprietary information, I will consume fruit juice, vegetable juice, herbal tea, and finally, more broth just before bed.
让我们从一个压轴戏开始，好吗？在接下来的三周里，我通往启蒙的道路是这样的：我醒来，去洗手间，给自己灌肠。你没听错。温水、甘菊茶和八滴柠檬汁。我要把它憋住15分钟，躺在浴室地板上的毛巾上，通过阅读某种灵性文献来打发时间。我选择了《纽约时报》。接着是洗澡，早餐喝8到12盎司清澈的蔬菜汤。在一天中的其他时间，由于这是受版权保护的专有信息，我不能具体说是什么时候，我会喝果汁、蔬菜汁、草药茶，最后在睡前再喝一些肉汤。
I'm on an extended fast. I find my particular fast on the web. It's like a correspondence spa. For about $300, I am provided with an exhaustive regimen that includes the recipe for the special broth I will be drinking, along with a schedule for the additional juices and herbal teas that I will also be drinking. And I will be guided by the center's founder and president, a man I'll call Brian, based in California. I can email him with all of my questions. I make sure to tell my doctor, and Ira also agrees to check in with me every now and then.
我正在进行一次延长的禁食。我在网上找到了我这种特殊的禁食法。这就像一个远程水疗中心。花大约300美元，我得到了一份详尽的方案，包括我将要喝的特殊肉汤的食谱，以及我将要喝的额外果汁和草药茶的时间表。我将由中心创始人和总裁指导，一个我称之为布莱恩的男人，他住在加利福尼亚。我可以通过电子邮件向他提出所有问题。我确保告诉了我的医生，艾拉也同意偶尔查看一下我的情况。
David, this is the first day of your fast.
大卫，这是你禁食的第一天。
Yes.
是的。
Are you very, very hungry right now?
你现在非常非常饿吗？
I'm not very, very hungry. I'm quite sleepy. And I'm finding it rather difficult to talk this much.
我不算非常非常饿。我相当困。而且我发现要说这么多话相当困难。
Wow! It's taxing.
哇！这很费力。
Yeah. And that kind of scares me, actually.
是的。事实上，这让我有点害怕。
People who stop taking in carbohydrates have to make this switch from one kind of fuel to the other kind of fuel from carbohydrates to these very tiny fat cells known as ketones.
停止摄入碳水化合物的人必须从一种燃料切换到另一种燃料，即从碳水化合物切换到这些被称为酮的微小脂肪细胞。
This is Dr. Lisa Sanders who, as part of a team at Yale, spent the past five years analyzing the science behind over 700 different diets. She's also written a book based on this work called The Perfect Fit Diet. On day one of the fast, she tells me my sluggishness is due to this switch from carbohydrates to ketones.
这是丽莎·桑德斯医生，作为耶鲁大学团队的一员，她花了过去五年时间分析了700多种不同饮食背后的科学。她还根据这项工作写了一本书，名叫《完美的饮食》。在禁食的第一天，她告诉我，我的迟钝是由于这种从碳水化合物到酮的转换。
When that happens, people feel sort of tired and out of sorts. Some people describe feeling a headache. After a couple of days, people often return to feeling very normal even though they're not taking in any carbohydrates, even though they're not taking in their usual supply of gasoline. Then people say that they don't feel hungry at all. There's something about ketones that kills your appetite. Food is not an issue for them anymore.
当这种情况发生时，人们会感到有点累和不对劲。有些人描述说会头痛。几天后，人们通常会恢复到感觉非常正常的状态，即使他们没有摄入任何碳水化合物，即使他们没有摄入平时的汽油供应。然后人们说他们根本不觉得饿。酮类物质有一种能抑制食欲的东西。对他们来说，食物不再是一个问题。
What I've been reading is that, yes, they do predict a few days at the beginning where it's going to be quite difficult, and then comes a kind of a clarity, peace, and clearheadedness. And I was wondering whether there was a physiological reason that you could think of that might account for this sort of enhanced clarity?
我读到的是，是的，他们确实预测开始的几天会相当困难，然后会出现一种清晰、平静和头脑清醒的状态。我想知道是否有一种生理原因你可以想到可以解释这种增强的清晰感？
Hm. Well, hm. Let me think about that for a second. Ketones are your brain's preferred fuel. So maybe there's something about that that makes people feel good.
嗯。好吧，嗯。让我考虑一下。酮是你大脑的首选燃料。所以也许这其中有什么东西让人们感觉良好。
The website where I bought this fast explains my changes in mood very differently. It is not about ketones or switching fuel sources. It is about toxins. According to my fasting center, as an urban North American living in the 21st century, I have a surpassingly toxic body with an average of 5 to 10 pounds of damaging impurities housed in my cells. My nerves and organs are apparently coated with this ubiquitous, sludgy film of judgment-clouding, character-distorting poison. Chemical fertilizers, remnants of medication, heavy metals, artificial colorings, all conspire to make me less than the best David I can be.
我购买这个禁食方案的网站对我的情绪变化解释得完全不同。这与酮或切换燃料来源无关。这是关于毒素的问题。根据我的禁食中心，作为一个生活在21世纪的城市北美居民，我的身体极其有毒，我的细胞里含有平均5到10磅的有害杂质。我的神经和器官显然被覆盖着一层无处不在的、污浊的判断力云遮蔽、性格扭曲的毒素电影中。化学肥料、药物残留、重金属、人造色素，所有这些都勾结起来，让我无法成为最好的大卫。
Under this logic, the reason I feel so rotten to these first few days of my fast, is that as the poisons leave the relatively inert resting places they have carved out in my cells and pass through my skin and, most importantly, my colon, they will once again exert their poisonous effects. Stuff that hurts going in will hurt coming out, I am told. And it's all about stuff coming out, so to speak. Every fast I research is intensely concerned with notions of purity and cleanliness and the need to flush oneself out, whether through laxative teas and chugging a gallon of saltwater or, in my case, the enemas. Did I mention that I have to do a daily enema?
根据这个逻辑，我在这禁食头几天感到如此糟糕的原因是，当毒素离开它们在细胞中刻下的相对惰性的静止位置，并通过我的皮肤，最重要的是，我的结肠排出时，它们会再次发挥它们的毒性作用。我被告知，进去时伤害身体的东西，出来时也会伤害身体。而且一切都是关于“出来”的东西，可以这么说。我研究的每一次禁食都非常关注纯洁和清洁的概念，以及需要通过泻药茶和灌下一加仑盐水，或者在我的情况下，灌肠来冲洗自己的需求。我提到过我必须每天灌肠吗？
The fixation is on the eradication of these supposed pollutants, 5 to 10 pounds of them. That is the size of a robust newborn baby. It seems like an awful lot of poison in an ostensibly healthy person. Dr. Sanders says there's little scientific proof of this.
这种执念在于根除这些所谓的污染物，5到10磅之多。那是一个健壮的新生儿的大小。对于一个表面上健康的人来说，这似乎是太多的毒素了。桑德斯医生说，这几乎没有什么科学证明。
I've never seen any evidence of 5 to 10 pounds of toxins stored in our bodies. Most things don't do much and don't get around that much. Our cells are pretty selective about what they take up and what they don't take up as far as I know, as far as we've been able to show.
我从未见过任何证据表明我们的身体里储存了5到10磅的毒素。大多数东西不会有太大作用，也不会到处跑。据我所知，据我们能够证明的程度，我们的细胞对摄取什么和不摄取什么是非常有选择性的。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And purification of your body, we live in a dirtier and dirtier world. And yet our lives are longer and longer. Go figure.
关于你的身体净化，我们生活在一个越来越脏的世界里。然而我们的寿命却越来越长。谁知道呢。
So would this be pseudoscience?
那么这会是伪科学吗？
I think so. I mean, there's a lot of stuff we don't know about the human body. There's no question about it. And so that's why I can't just out of hand say this is a whole bunch of hogwash. We should have studies. If this is true, then they should be able to show us that people who do this are healthier in some measurable, tangible way than people who don't do it and not just those who volunteer to do it. Because obviously, this is going to appeal to somebody who's very interested in their health and their well-being, somebody who cares about what they eat and that they exercise correctly. So this is not going to be science. This might be beliefs. And societies are filled with beliefs about things that are good for you, that may or may not be-- that may have no scientific merit whatsoever, but that doesn't mean that they don't work. It doesn't mean that they do work either.
我想是的。我的意思是，关于人体还有很多我们不知道的事情。毫无疑问。所以这就是为什么我不能直接说这是一堆胡说八道。我们应该进行研究。如果这是真的，那么他们应该能够向我们展示，做这种事情的人在某些可衡量的、有形的方式上比不做的人更健康，而不仅仅是那些自愿这样做的人。因为显然，这会吸引那些非常关注自己健康和幸福的人，那些关心自己吃什么、锻炼是否正确的人。所以这不是科学。这可能是信仰。社会充满了关于什么是对你有好处的信仰，这些信仰可能——可能没有任何科学价值，但这并不意味着它们不起作用。这也不意味着它们确实起作用。
The fasting program I'm on doesn't just promise weight loss, greater energy, and enhance virility, but also insight, clarity, and inner peace. And to be quite frank, I could do with some inner peace.
我参加的禁食计划不仅承诺减肥、增强活力和增强性能力，还承诺洞察力、清晰和内心的平静。说实话，我确实需要一些内心的平静。
Do you have any advice for me?
你对我有什么建议吗？
Well, I would not think of this as a health experiment. I wouldn't think of this is a weight loss experiment. I would think of this as a spiritual experiment.
嗯，我不会把这当作一个健康实验。我不会把它当作一个减肥实验。我会把它当作一个精神实验。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I have to say, I read about these holy people who fast for weeks at a time and have these visions. And you really don't know what to do with it because you know that something happened to them, but they interpreted what happened to them through their spiritual interests. I'd be interested in seeing how a rationalist would interpret these same feelings. I hope you see something. I hope you have a good experience.
我必须说，我读过关于这些禁食数周并产生幻觉的圣人。你真的不知道该怎么处理它，因为你知道他们身上发生了什么，但他们通过他们的精神兴趣解释了发生在他们身上的事情。我很想看看一个理性主义者会如何解释这些同样的感受。我希望你看到一些东西。我希望你有一个好的体验。
By day four, the day I'm supposed to have turned the corner, I am certainly feeling better. I am no longer hungry, and the headaches and listlessness are largely gone. I feel more or less normal. But that's it. No brilliant shafts of light piercing the clouds, no strange hallucinatory visitations. By day five, I have more energy. I even manage to make it to the gym.
到了第四天，我应该转弯的那一天，我确实感觉好多了。我不再饿了，头痛和无精打采也基本消失了。我感觉或多或少正常。但就是这样。没有明亮的光束刺破云层，没有奇怪的幻觉访问。到了第五天，我有了更多的精力。我甚至设法去了健身房。
On day six, I definitely feel something, although not what I expected. I rise early. My energy is high. I feel great. I stand in the bathroom on top of the  spread-out newspaper and give myself my weekly haircut. And then suddenly, my heart begins to race. I am overcome with a shaky weakness and the distinct feeling that I cannot trust my body to do what it is meant to do. Or rather, that what my body is meant to do in that moment is to pass out and have me crack my head against the cold, unforgiving edge of the bath. I get dressed and go to see my doctor a block away. I buy a banana on the way just in case everything goes to hell and I have to end this thing.
在第六天，我确实感觉到了一些东西，尽管不是我预期的那样。我起得很早。我的精力很高。我感觉棒极了。我站在铺开的报纸上面的浴室里，给自己剪了每周一次的头发。然后突然，我的心开始狂跳。我被一种颤抖的虚弱感所征服，并且有一种明确的感觉，即我不能相信我的身体能做它应该做的事情。或者说，我的身体在那一刻注定要做的是晕倒，让我的头撞到冷酷无情的浴缸边缘。我穿上衣服，去看了离这里一个街区远的医生。我在路上买了一根香蕉，以防万一一切都搞砸了，我不得不结束这一切。
My doctor takes my blood pressure and my pulse, both normal. He's not crazy about the idea of me fasting, but tells me that I am essentially fine, and I return home, my fast intact, the banana uneaten. I call Ira to tell him about it.
医生量了我的血压和脉搏，都很正常。他并不赞成我禁食的想法，但告诉我我基本上没事，我回到了家，我的禁食还在继续，那根香蕉也没吃。我打电话给艾拉告诉他这件事。
Now, I've got this banana, sitting on my desk like a loaded gun. You know, and wasn't it Chekhov who said, you know, if you introduce a gun in the first act, it's got to go off by the third. Here is Ira's suggestion of what to do with this taunting fruit. Maybe it's just the fast, but he seems to be talking double quick.
现在，这根香蕉放在我的桌子上，像一把装满子弹的枪。你知道，契诃夫不是说过吗，如果在第一幕中放了一把枪，它必须在第三幕中发射。这是艾拉对于如何处理这个嘲弄我的水果的建议。也许只是因为禁食，但他说话的速度似乎快了一倍。
Throw it out the window.
把它扔出窗外。
No, I think what I'm going to do is--
不，我想我要做的是——
Throw it out the window.
把它扔出窗外。
Well, Ira, I live on a street. Throwing it out a window could hit somebody. It's actually against the law probably.
嗯，艾拉，我住在街道上。把它扔出窗外可能会打到人。这实际上可能是违法的。
You live on the first floor. Throw it out the window.
你住在二楼。把它扔出窗外。
I don't live on the first floor. This is fascinating. Should I be wearing anything special when I throw it out the window?
我不住在二楼。这太迷人了。我把它扔出窗外时应该穿什么特别的衣服吗？
Does it make you feel safer to have the banana there? Or is the banana taunting you, like seeing--
香蕉放在那儿让你感觉更安全吗？还是香蕉在嘲弄你，就像看到——
The banana is not really taunting me. There was a point when I thought this morning-- well, I thought a few things and I thought, well, that's it. It's over. And then I thought, ah! Back to the world of food, of interest and diversion. Yahoo! But then I felt like a failure and kind of back to square one, like oh God! Now, how am I going to get through another week of this?
香蕉并没有真正嘲弄我。今天早上确实有一个点——嗯，我想了几件事，我想，嗯，就这样了。结束了。然后我想，啊！回到食物、兴趣和消遣的世界。耶！但随后我觉得自己是个失败者，有点回到原点，就像哦天哪！现在，我该怎么熬过接下来的一个星期？
Well, it's time for me to make my broth. I have to make this every two days or so. It serves to provide me with electrolytes so that your heart doesn't stop. I was thinking about this lack of enlightenment, but I'm feeling and I sort of thought like I was that woman in the movie Manhattan who was at a party and she says to Woody Allen something like I finally had an orgasm, and my analyst told me it was the wrong kind. I just fell like how come all the other kids are getting enlightened and I'm not?
好吧，是时候做我的肉汤了。我每隔两天左右就要做一次。它用来为我提供电解质，这样你的心脏就不会停止跳动。我当时在想这种启蒙的缺失，但我感觉到了，我有点觉得自己像电影《曼哈顿》里的那个女人，她在派对上对伍迪·艾伦说，她终于有了性高潮，但她的分析师告诉她那是错误的那种。我只是觉得为什么其他孩子都得到了启蒙，而我却没有？
Day nine. Here's something else I'm not feeling, something Ira keeps egging me on about.
第九天。这是另一件我没有感受到的事情，艾拉一直怂恿我的事情。
Have you started to feel superior?
你开始感到优越了吗？
Am I walking around, he wants to know, an ethereal creature of light and air, passing by the falafel stand, for example, and looking disdainfully from my slender Olympian perch at the weak-willed humans who feel the need to stuff their gullets with something as earthbound and disgusting as solid nourishment? Not really, as it turns out. This fast hasn't lessened my usual feelings of venality and guilt. If anything, they've increased a little because my days are taken up in this narcissistic rumination about my intake and my output. Between the hours of making the broth and the enemas, this is one of the most self-obsessed things I have ever done in my life. And I say that as a first-person journalist.
他想知道，我是否像一个轻盈空灵的生物一样四处走动，路过沙拉三明治摊，并从我苗条的奥林匹克栖木上，轻蔑地看着那些脆弱的人类，因为他们需要用像固体食物那样世俗而恶心的东西来填饱肚子？事实证明，并非如此。这次禁食并没有减少我通常的卑劣和内疚感。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是它们稍微增加了一些，因为我的日子都花在这种关于我的摄入和排出的自恋沉思中。在做肉汤和灌肠的时间之间，这是我一生中做过的最以自我为中心的事情之一。而且我这是以第一人称记者的身份这么说的。
One night on the subway, I see a woman at the end of the car. She leans over to the people sitting next to her and asks in a quiet friendly, almost business-like tone, "Do you have any extra food I can buy off of you?" I can only hear her because the train is silent. She isn't standing in the middle of the car addressing us. She's just asking those within earshot. I walk over and give the woman a dollar before I get off at Union Square. "But do you have any extra food?" she asks me. I apologize and say that I do not have any extra food. But I know in that moment that there is neither clarity nor serenity enough in the world that would give me the chutzpah to tell her why not.
一天晚上在地铁上，我看到车厢尽头有一个女人。她俯身向坐在旁边的人询问，用一种安静、友好、几乎像谈生意一样的语气问：“你们有我可以买的额外食物吗？”只有因为火车很安静我才能听到她。她没有站在车厢中间跟我们说话。她只是问了那些在耳闻范围内的人。在我下车前往联合广场之前，我走过去给了那个女人一美元。“但你有什么额外的食物吗？”她问我。我道歉说我没有额外的食物。但我那一刻知道，世界上没有足够的清晰或宁静能给我勇气告诉她为什么没有。
Day 11. Brian advises everyone on the fast to keep it to themselves and not tell too many people. What I will find, I am told, is that those who know I am fasting will project their own worries or anti-fasting prejudices onto me, saying things like "you look too thin," whereas those who have no idea will simply think I look healthy and great. It seems true. My friends who do know I am fasting think I look gaunt. But then I go to synagogue for the baby-naming service of some friends' twins. I've lost 12 pounds. I wait for the compliments. I find out later that someone asked my friend Jeff, does David have cancer?
第11天。布莱恩建议每个人在禁食期间都要保密，不要告诉太多人。我被告知，我会发现那些知道我在禁食的人会把他们自己的担忧或反禁食偏见投射到我身上，说些“你看起来太瘦了”之类的话，而那些不知道的人只会觉得我看起来健康又棒。这似乎是真的。知道我在禁食的朋友觉得我看起来憔悴。但随后我去犹太教堂参加朋友的双胞胎命名仪式。我瘦了12磅。我等着恭维话。后来我发现有人问我的朋友杰夫，大卫是不是得了癌症？
Captain's log. I wonder if this is something. I'm curiously relaxed, as if my bones have been removed. How can I explain this? It is as if I have taken an anti-anxiety pill. I am aware of my problems and the things that concern me. Intellectually, they can still freak me out. But my physical anxiety response is gone.
船长日志。不知道这算不算什么。我出奇地放松，就像我的骨头被拆除了一样。我怎么解释呢？就好像我吃了抗焦虑药一样。我知道我的问题和困扰我的事情。理智上，它们仍然可以让我抓狂。但我的身体焦虑反应消失了。
On the street, a bike messenger zooms by dangerously close to me, nearly shearing off my kneecaps. I can only mutter, "Jerk," where once I might have hissed it. I cannot work myself up into a lather. Do I think, oh, hello, God's creature, fellow and bicycled human. Come ride freely. Let the wind carry you like a seedling, like a bird? No. What I thought was, jerk, I hope you are crushed beneath the wheels of a bus. But the difference was the venom that pulsed through my veins now had the restful back-and-forth rush of the ocean's waves. It's a pleasant feeling, certainly, but hardly seems worth the effort of weeks without food. If this is all there is, then I hate to say it, but Miss Peggy Lee was kind of right.
在街上，一个自行车快递员离我极近地飞驰而过，差点切掉我的膝盖。我只能嘟囔“混蛋”，而在以前我可能会发出嘶嘶声。我无法让自己怒不可遏。我在想，哦，你好，上帝的造物，骑自行车的同类。来吧，自由地骑行吧。让风像幼苗一样，像鸟儿一样带你走吗？不。我当时想的是，混蛋，我希望你被公共汽车轮子碾碎。但不同之处在于，在我血管里跳动的毒液现在有了海洋波浪般平静的起伏感。这确实是一种愉悦的感觉，但似乎不值得为了几周不吃东西而付出努力。如果这就是全部，那么我不想这么说，但佩吉·李小姐说得有点对。
Day 13 without food. It is the home stretch of the fast, and I have lost 14 pounds. I'm not hungry, but I am experiencing appetite. I find myself thinking about food a lot, cooking it almost more than eating it. I pour through books and surf the web for recipes: roast goose with prunes, brown butter madeleines, candied grapefruit peel, precisely the kind of oldy-worldy delicacies Hans Christian Andersen's Little Match Girl saw dancing before her eyes before she froze to death on the Copenhagen street.
第13天没有食物。这是禁食的冲刺阶段，我瘦了14磅。我不饿，但我正在经历食欲。我发现自己经常想食物，做饭的时间几乎比吃东西还多。我翻阅书籍，在网上冲浪寻找食谱：烤鹅配西梅、焦奶油玛德琳、糖渍葡萄柚皮，正是安徒生《卖火柴的小女孩》在哥本哈根街头冻死前，眼中跳舞的那种老式珍馐。
On the final day of fasting, I bound out of my house, a brilliantly blue and freezing day. I am feeling jaunty and alive, like a character in the movie who, newly in love, walks through the streets he thought he knew, only to find them vibrant and full of beautiful humanity, and he, a wonderful part of it all. He dances for a group of French children. He smiles with friendly commiseration at a young couple, flirts nonthreateningly with an old lady, telling her, "Madam, you smell delicious." He tips his hat to the cop.
禁食的最后一天，我从家里一跃而出，那是一个明亮、寒冷的日子。我感到轻快而充满活力，就像电影里的一个角色，新近陷入爱河，走在他以为熟悉的街道上，却发现它们充满活力，充满美丽的文明，而他，是这一切中美妙的一部分。他为一群法国孩子跳舞。他对着一对年轻夫妇露出友好的同情微笑，与一位老太太进行无威胁的调情，告诉她：“女士，你闻起来真香。”他向警察举了举帽子。
But it is not universal brotherhood that has me jazzed as I dance along. What I am thinking to myself is, hello world! Tomorrow I eat an apple! My high spirits are tempered with something else, though. A sheepishness that I have somehow failed to receive the thing that I should have, and here I am already out the door, and it's too late.
但我随着舞步跳动时感到的兴奋并非源于普遍的博爱。我内心想的是，你好，世界！明天我吃苹果！然而，我的高昂情绪被别的东西冲淡了。一种羞愧，因为我以某种方式未能获得我应该获得的东西，而现在我已经走出门口，太晚了。
When I tell Brian that I feel good but not markedly different, he doesn't hesitate to tell me that my experience is atypical. From Brian's perspective, I didn't approach this with an open mind. I need to talk to someone who's managed to achieve what I did not. I compare notes with Amy Warren, who has fasted five times.
当我告诉布莱恩我感觉很好但没有明显不同时，他毫不犹豫地告诉我，我的经历是不典型的。从布莱恩的角度来看，我没有以开放的心态接近这件事。我需要和那些成功做到我没做到的人谈谈。我比较了艾米·沃伦的笔记，她已经禁食了五次。
When I read the pamphlet, initially I was like, oh, this is all about cleansing and getting rid of toxins that have been building up in your system. And I found that first time I did the fast, that was the most satisfying in terms of feeling that the toxins were leaving my body.
当我读到小册子时，起初我觉得，哦，这全是关于清洁和摆脱在你系统中积聚的毒素。我发现我第一次禁食时，就感到毒素正在离开我的身体，这在那种感觉上是最令人满足的。
And you felt that that happened?
你觉得那真的发生了？
Yes, I saw it. I mean, I saw it.
是的，我看到了。我的意思是，我看到了。
What form did it take?
它采取了什么形式？
Well, is it appropriate to talk about on the radio?
嗯，在广播里谈论这个合适吗？
Oh, OK, so it took that form. I see.
哦，好的，所以它采取了那种形式。我明白了。
I mean, it might sound really insane and gross. But the stuff that would come out of you, you would be, like, where-- what is that? You wouldn't even know what it was. It looked like from a movie, like, it looked like unreal.
我的意思是，这听起来可能真的很疯狂和恶心。但从你身体里出来的东西，你会想，哪里——那是什么？你甚至不知道那是什么。看起来像电影里的，看起来不真实。
I was just going to say, by a movie, you don't mean Room with a View?
我正想说，说电影，你不是指《看得见风景的房间》吧？
No. I mean a movie like in Star Wars where in that sewer and the water and all that sludge and slime and weird bubbly things, and just misshapened, odd-- what is that? It's all there, and it comes out of you. And then you're like, what? And when everything's running clear, like water from a faucet, you feel like you're new, like you're a new person. And you feel like you're sexy and like alive. And you feel like you're somehow your highest self. There's nothing you couldn't do.
不。我的意思是像《星球大战》那样的电影，在那个下水道里，水和所有的污泥、粘液和奇怪的泡沫东西，还有形状扭曲、奇怪的——那是什么？它就在那里，从你身体里出来。然后你会想，什么？当一切都变得清澈，就像水龙头里的水一样，你觉得你是新的，就像你是换了一个人。你觉得你很性感，很有生命力。你觉得自己以某种方式成了最高的自我。没有什么你做不到的。
Really?
真的吗？
In terms of your life and your goals and everything, you feel sort of focused and clarified and like you know what you want to do, and you feel like you could do anything. You feel empowered.
在你的生活、目标和一切方面，你觉得你有点专注和清晰，你觉得你知道你想做什么，而且你觉得你可以做任何事情。你觉得自己被赋予了权力。
Really? Wow! I did it wrong.
真的吗？哇！我做错了。
Oh, no, you didn't do it wrong at all.
哦，不，你一点也没做错。
I think I did, but it's OK. But I didn't feel that clarity. I mean, I feel good. But I feel just as good when I've had a tiny bit of caffeine and, you know, that it's exactly it, and I've exercised or something. So I don't really know. I feel like everybody's like, oh, where were you? Paris. Oh, did you see the Eiffel Tower? Or the Louvre? The Louvre, I couldn't see that. That somehow, I managed to miss everything. They would say like, oh, well, how was the food? Was it wonderful? Well, there was a vending machine and some Junior Mints.
我觉得我做了，但没关系。但我没感觉到那种清晰。我的意思是，我感觉很好。但我喝了一点咖啡因，你知道，就是那样，我锻炼了一下，我也会感觉很好。所以我真的不知道。我觉得大家就像，哦，你去哪儿了？巴黎。哦，你看到埃菲尔铁塔了吗？还是卢浮宫？卢浮宫，我没看到。我以某种方式错过了所有东西。他们会说，哦，好吧，食物怎么样？美妙吗？嗯，有一台自动售货机和一些薄荷糖。
In a little unscientific survey conducted by the producers of this show, calling around to friends, and friends of friends who'd fasted, and even four people who specifically did my fast, albeit for much longer, they found that everyone felt great physically, energetic and alert, and nearly everybody spoke about a clarity of mind. But only one person seemed to feel more than that. This woman said that for a moment while driving, her spirit was filled up and she was overcome with a sense of total well-being, of a level and profundity she'd never felt before. Amy's experience was more typical.
在节目制作人进行的一次小规模非科学调查中，他们给禁食的朋友和朋友的朋友打了电话，甚至包括四位专门进行我的禁食法的长久禁食者，他们发现每个人身体上都感觉很好，充满活力和警觉，几乎每个人都谈到了头脑的清晰。但只有一个人似乎感受到了更多。这个女人说，在开车时有一瞬间，她的精神被填满了，她被一种前所未有的全面幸福感所征服。艾米的经历更典型。
When I first started doing it, I was thinking like, yeah, I'm going to-- it's going to be like spiritual nirvana. I'm going to recognize the universe in a way that I've never recognized the universe. But I really feel like that expectation, you know, it was-- it never happened.
当我刚开始做的时候，我在想，是的，我会——它会像精神上的涅槃。我会以一种我从未认识过的方式认识宇宙。但我真的觉得那种期望，你知道，它是——它从来没有发生过。
It never happened?
它从来没有发生过？
No. Not in a way that I would have sort of expected it to. I mean, I did definitely-- I always felt a sense of clarity and focus, different than any other time in my life, but I never felt like it was a religious or spiritual thing.
不。不是我预期的那种方式。我的意思是，我确实总是感觉到一种清晰和专注，与我生命中任何时候都不同，但我从没觉得它是一种宗教或精神上的东西。
It's Wednesday morning at about 7:30, and today is the apple. On the first day I'm allowed to eat, before I have my apple, I'm supposed to mix a tablespoon of bran and flaxseed into the broth. It makes it as thick as porridge, and it knocks me out.
现在是周三早上7:30左右，今天是苹果日。在被允许吃东西的第一天，吃苹果之前，我应该在一勺麸皮和亚麻籽中混合肉汤。它让它变得像粥一样浓稠，这让我很受挫。
OK, it's an hour and a half later. I hadn't thought that eating would be quite this difficult. And I suppose I'd better try and eat this apple. It's very strange. I looked forward to it for so long, and now it just feels like a little bit of an ordeal. All right. [BITES AN APPLE AND CHEWS] Here I am, chewing fruit again. I almost feel like I was never away from it.
好的，一个半小时后了。我没想到吃东西会这么困难。我想我最好试着吃这个苹果。这很奇怪。我期待它这么久，现在它感觉像是一种折磨。好吧。[咬一口苹果并咀嚼]我又在这儿吃水果了。我几乎觉得我从未离开过它。
Right when I started the fast, I had the briefest romantic notion that it wouldn't just work, but it really would be the magic bullet. I entertained the fantasy that the fast would short-circuit logic, and somehow, my problems, such as they are, didn't need the talk and the scrutiny. They needed this. There was even a moment where I could see my problems, feel them, impacted and concentrated into a grey, plaque-like obstruction. A thick, squat blockage the shape and size of a scallop somewhere in the channels of my body. And I thought that this was the way that they would be pulverized and broken up and flushed away.
当我刚开始禁食时，我有一个极其短暂的浪漫念头，认为它不仅会奏效，而且它真的会是魔法子弹。我幻想着禁食会绕过逻辑，以某种方式，我的问题，比如它们是什么，不需要谈话和审查。它们需要这个。甚至有那么一刻，我能看到我的问题，感受到它们，像灰色的、斑块状的阻塞一样冲击和集中。一个厚实、低矮、大小形状像扇贝的堵塞物在我身体的通道里。我以为这就是它们被粉碎、打散并冲走的方式。
Now that I've finished the fast and am on the other side, it's hard to remember exactly what I was waiting for, although I do know that it was something wholly unfamiliar and thrilling, like a new color, one I'd never seen before. Not a mixture, no trace of blue or yellow or red. What would that look like? Even though our physical world makes the existence of such a thing basically impossible, I'd still really like to see that.
既然我已经完成了禁食，身处另一边，很难准确记得我在等待什么，虽然我知道那是一种完全陌生和令人兴奋的东西，就像一种新颜色，我以前从未见过的那种。不是混合物，没有蓝色、黄色或红色的痕迹。那看起来会是什么样子？尽管我们的物理世界使得这种东西的存在基本上是不可能的，但我仍然真的很想看看。
David Rakoff. He's put the story of his fast into his brand-new book Don't Get Too Comfortable.
大卫·拉科夫。他把禁食的故事写进了他的新书《别太舒服》。
[MUSIC - "EAT IT" BY WEIRD AL YANKOVIC]
[音乐 - 韦尔·奥尔·扬科维奇的《吃掉它》]
Act Three. Mystery Train. We close our show today with the story of two people, each earning for certain future, though not necessarily the same future. Hillary Frank remembers the story.
第三章。神秘列车。今天我们以两个人的故事结束节目，每个人都渴望某种未来，尽管不一定是同一个未来。希拉里·弗兰克记得这个故事。
The lights were out. We were stopped on the tracks, and Danielle wasn't happy. "All I wanted," she said, "was to have McDonald's with my boyfriend." It was supposed to be their big Friday night in Boston. They were sitting diagonally behind me. Danielle and her boyfriend Donny had gotten on the train in Providence a few stops after mine. Eavesdropping in the dark, I learned their names, that they were 15-- four years younger than me-- and that they were surprised to see the girl sitting by the window behind me. Donny's surprise was pleasant. "Man, Cynthia, I didn't expect to run into you," and Danielle's was more like, "yeah, didn't think I'd run into you."
灯熄灭了。我们停在铁轨上，丹妮尔很不高兴。“我想要的，”她说，“只是和我的男朋友去吃麦当劳。”这本该是他们在波士顿度过的一个盛大的周五晚上。他们坐在我斜后方。丹妮尔和她的男朋友多尼在Providence我下车的几站后上了火车。在黑暗中偷听，我得知了他们的名字，他们才15岁——比我小四岁——而且他们很惊讶看到那个坐在我后面靠窗的女孩。多尼的惊讶很愉快。“天哪，辛西娅，我没想到会遇见你，”而丹妮尔的惊讶更像是，“是啊，没想到会遇见你。”
Other than an elderly couple in the back, we were the only people in the car. Cynthia told them it was her 18th birthday. She invited Danielle and Donny to the party her sister was throwing for her in Boston. "I'll get you good and wasted," she told them. Donny practically cheered. Danielle must have punched him because he winced out loud. "I ain't doin' none of that," she said. "Yeah, you are," Donny teased. "You're gettin' doped." "Am not," she said. "You know I can't do that. None of it. You know." "Come on," Cynthia prodded. "It'll make your man happy." "No," Danielle repeated. She sounded like she was going to cry. "I can't. I can't."
除了后面的一对老年夫妇，车厢里只有我们。辛西娅告诉他们这是她18岁生日。她邀请丹妮尔和多尼去她姐姐在波士顿为她举办的派对。“我会让你喝得烂醉，”她告诉他们。多尼差点欢呼起来。丹妮尔一定打了他的拳头，因为他大声叫痛。“我才不要做那种事，”她说。“你会的，”多尼取笑说。“你会嗨起来的。”“才不会，”她说。“你知道我不能那样做。根本不行。你知道。”“来吧，”辛西娅催促道。“这会让你的男人高兴的。”“不，”丹妮尔重复道。她听起来快要哭了。“我不能。我不能。”
The lights came back on. The engine revved, and we inched along the tracks. Everyone sat quietly for a minute. Cynthia spoke first. "How long you been together?" "Five months," Danielle answered. Cynthia seemed to be working up to something. "How long have you known?" "Three months," Danielle said quietly. Cynthia's seat creaked. "I was once, too," she told Danielle. "A couple years ago." Pregnant, I thought.
灯亮了。引擎轰鸣，我们沿着轨道慢慢爬行。每个人都静静地坐了一分钟。辛西娅先开口。“你们在一起多久了？”“五个月，”丹妮尔回答。辛西娅似乎在酝酿什么。“你知道多久了？”“三个月，”丹妮尔低声说。辛西娅的座位吱呀作响。“我曾经也是，”她告诉丹妮尔。“几年前。”怀孕了，我想。
We were back up to speed. The conductor poked his head into our car to tell us we'd been delayed because some juveniles had placed shopping carts on the tracks. It seemed strange for him to be using the word juveniles when we were all teenagers ourselves.
我们又回到了速度。列车长把头探进车厢，告诉我们延误是因为一些青少年把购物推车放在了轨道上。当我们在座的都是青少年时，他使用“青少年”这个词显得很奇怪。
Cynthia asked Donny if he loved Danielle. "Of course I love her," he said. "She's mine." "If you really did, then you wouldn't have kissed Angel," Danielle snapped. "Angel?" Cynthia asked. She scooted over to the aisle seat. "Yeah," Danielle said. "He kissed her two weeks ago, even when he knew she had AIDS." "Not a real kiss," Donny said. "What do you mean not a real kiss?" Cynthia asked. "It was nothing," he told her. "Yeah right. Nothing," Danielle shot back.
辛西娅问多尼是否爱丹妮尔。“我当然爱她，”他说。“她是我的。”“如果你真的爱她，那你就不会亲安吉尔，”丹妮尔厉声说。“安吉尔？”辛西娅问。她滑向过道边的座位。“是啊，”丹妮尔说。“他两周前亲了她，即使他知道她有艾滋病。”“不是真正的亲吻，”多尼说。“什么叫不是真正的亲吻？”辛西娅问。“什么都不是，”他告诉她。“是啊，对。什么都不是，”丹妮尔反驳道。
Cynthia leaned over the aisle towards Donny. "Show me," she said. "Show you what?" Cynthia slid back to the window seat and patted the cushion beside her. "Show me how you kissed Angel," she told him. As Donnie crossed the aisle, Danielle yelled at him. "Don't show her! Tell her!" "It's OK," Cynthia said calmly. "I mean no disrespect. Say it with me, no disrespect." "Fine," Danielle mumbled through clenched teeth. "No disrespect." "So show me," Cynthia said.
辛西娅越过过道向多尼倾斜。“给我看看，”她说。“看什么？”辛西娅滑回靠窗的座位，拍了拍旁边的垫子。“给我看看你是怎么亲安吉尔的，”她告诉他。当多尼穿过过道时，丹妮尔对他大喊。“别给她看！告诉她！”“没关系，”辛西娅平静地说。“我没有不尊重。跟我一起说，没有不尊重。”“好吧，”丹妮尔咬牙切齿地咕哝着。“没有不尊重。”“所以给我看看，”辛西娅说。
There was a soft smooching sound, which must have been a peck on the cheek, because both of the girls shouted "No way!" in unison. "I know that's not how he did it," Danielle said. Cynthia laughed. "Show me for real," she commanded.
传来了轻柔的亲吻声，那一定是脸颊上的轻吻，因为两个女孩异口同声地喊道：“没门！”“我知道他不是那样做的，”丹妮尔说。辛西娅笑了。“来真的给我看看，”她命令道。
Tonguey mouth smacks were followed by Danielle tearing at Donny's back. There was slapping and whining verging on tears, and Cynthia's voice saying, "Chill, girl. I stuck my tongue in his mouth, not the other way around," as if that made it OK. Then she added, "You kissed Angel like that? You can't love this one that much."
带舌头的嘴巴撞击声之后是丹妮尔抓扯多尼的背部。有拍打和近乎哭泣的抱怨，还有辛西娅的声音说：“冷静点，女孩。我把舌头伸进了他的嘴里，而不是反过来，”好像那让这变得可以接受了。然后她补充道：“你就是这样亲安吉尔的？你不可能有多爱这个。”
It went on like this for around 20 minutes. Cynthia asking Donny if he'd ever cheat on Danielle. Donny saying no. Cynthia saying, "You wouldn't? Even if I did this to you?" Donnie buckling to temptation, and Danielle grumbling in her corner with occasional outbursts of fury.
这种情况持续了大约20分钟。辛西娅问多尼是否会对丹妮尔不忠。多尼说不会。辛西娅说：“你不会吗？即使我对你做这个？”多尼屈服于诱惑，丹妮尔在角落里咕哝着，偶尔爆发出一阵愤怒。
Finally, Cynthia stopped her come-ons and said, "You are sick. You would do all that with me and you say you love her?" "But I do," Donny said uncertainly. "I'm going to be with her 'til the day I die." "You should dump him," Cynthia told Danielle. Then she asked Donny if he had a place to stay. Danielle answered for him. "25 Maple Street with me and my mom." "Well, if that ever changes," Cynthia said, "you'll always have a place in Boston at my sister's apartment. You can see it right now if you come to the party."
最后，辛西娅停止了挑逗，说：“你有病。你会和我做这一切，然后你说你爱她？”“但我确实爱，”多尼不确定地说。“我会和她在一起直到我死的那天。”“你应该甩了他，”辛西娅告诉丹妮尔。然后她问多尼有没有地方住。丹妮尔替他回答了。“枫树街25号，我和我妈那里。”“好吧，如果情况有变，”辛西娅说，“你在波士顿我姐姐公寓里总有一席之地。如果你来参加派对，你现在就可以看到它。”
The train slowed as we entered Back Bay station. "We're going," Donny announced. "I'm going to McDonald's," Danielle said. "Girl, come on. It'll be fun," Cynthia said. "She's going," Donny said. "She's going and gettin' so doped." "Am not." They were still going back and forth like this by the time we got off the train. I stood there watching them on the platform, wondering what Danielle would end up doing.
火车驶入后湾站时减速了。“我们要走了，”多尼宣布。“我要去吃麦当劳，”丹妮尔说。“女孩，来吧。会很有趣的，”辛西娅说。“她要去，”多尼说。“她要去嗨起来。”“才不会。”当我们需要下火车时，他们还在争论。我站在站台上看着他们，好奇丹妮尔最终会做什么。
I still think of her sometimes. I end the evening in my head. On bad days, Danielle goes to the party. She watches Donny drink spiked punch and smoke pot and maybe settle into a corner with a cute girl in a halter top. Sometimes she winds up at McDonald's by herself, washing down a big Mac and supersized fries with a chocolate milkshake. But on good days, Danielle crosses the tracks, sits quietly on a bench, and waits for the next train back to Providence.
我偶尔还会想起她。我在脑海里结束了这个夜晚。在糟糕的日子里，丹妮尔去了派对。她看着多尼喝着加了料的酒，抽着大麻，也许和一个穿挂脖衫的漂亮女孩在角落里安定下来。有时她独自一人去了麦当劳，用巧克力奶昔冲下一份巨无霸和超大号薯条。但在美好的日子里，丹妮尔穿过铁轨，安静地坐在长椅上，等待下一班回Providence的火车。
Hillary Frank is the author of the novels Better Than Running at Night and I Can't Tell You.
希拉里·弗兰克是小说《好过在夜里奔跑》和《我不能告诉你》的作者。
[MUSIC - "WITH ARMS OUTSTRETCHED" BY RILO KILEY]
[音乐 - Rilo Kiley的《伸出双臂》]
Our program was produced today  by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production now from Todd Bachmann, [? Kelsey Betts, and ?] Chris Ladd. Music for our original "I Wish" song at the top of today's program was composed and perform by Mr. Brian Morris. Thanks to Mary Gaffney for recording that for us. Thanks also to Beth Miller, Karen Gardner, Michael Saw, Tom Stempel, Andreas Buchinger, Dennis Paulson, Jorge Just, and Carrie Willis. Our website: www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯和莎拉·凯尼格参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。现在的制作由托德·巴赫曼、凯尔西·贝茨和克里斯·拉德担任。今天节目开头原创“我希望”之歌的音乐由布莱恩·莫里斯先生创作和表演。感谢玛丽·加夫尼为我们录制了它。也要感谢贝丝·米勒、凯伦·加德纳、迈克尔·索、汤姆·斯腾佩尔、安德烈亚斯·布欣格、丹尼斯·保尔森、豪尔赫·贾斯特和凯莉·威利斯。我们的网站：www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。或者你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who mysteriously says to me every morning when he sees me at the office, "Madam, you smell delicious!" I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他每天早上在办公室见到我时都会神秘地说：“女士，你闻起来真香！”我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
[MUSIC - "YOU'RE CRAZY FOR TAKING THE BUS" BY JONATHAN RICHMAN]
[音乐 - 乔纳森·里奇曼的《你疯了去坐公交车》]